für Bayern für Deutschland für die CSU
auf geht's liebe Freundin und Freunde
wir starten durch danke schön ja ja das
reicht nicht war jetzt keine starke Rede
ne wissen sie
selbst es war eine eine großartige Rede
die auf Sachlichkeit nicht auf K sondern
Markus Söder hat die Probleme die
Herausforderungen beschrieben und auch
Lösungen angeboten Sachlichkeit brauchen
wir hier gar nicht wir brauchen Skandale
und die wer ich jetzt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Herr stäuber schönen guten Tag ich bin
heute hier ich möchte jetzt CSU
helfen das glauben sie mir nicht das
glaub ich bei den Freien Wählern läuft
jetzt so super weil eiwanger diesen
Skandal hatte diese Jugendsünde und
jetzt suche ich nach Jugendsünden von
Herrn Söder sie kennen den Mann was hat
Herr Söder für Jugend wollen doch mal
mehr darüber unterhalten wer hat die
Kompetenz in diesen Schwierigkeiten also
doch nicht über Söder
reden ich weiß wie man so Kampagnen
macht wie es richtig läuft er braucht
jetzt einfach eine Kampagne wie eiwanger
und muss s dann in die Opferrolle ganz
schnell und dann wird werden die Leute
ihn wählen das war genial von eiwanger
das braucht Söder jetzt auch ganz klare
Sache das braucht Söder nicht eiwanger
hat's nicht gebrachtt und er hat auch
gar nicht initiiert und das waren auch
die Medien völlig überflüssig wir können
das doch leisten die Medien nein was
halten sie von folgender
skandalschlagzeile Söder hat mich
begrapscht jetzt spricht der
Baum Geburtsurkunde aufgetaucht Söder
hat preußischen
Migrationshintergrund also das wäre ganz
schlecht er kommt ja schon aus Franken
das ist ja dann auch nur 50% Bayern also
insofern wäre es nicht gut was ist
schlimmer Franke oder
Preuße ja schon Preuße es gibt ein Black
facing Skandal
wer soll das sein Söder ist das wie wer
soll das sein jetzt verleugnen sie ihn
doch nicht ihr Chef also schlecht
gemacht schlecht schlecht gemacht das
ist sein Kostüm das ist keine Montage
das hat er wirklich so angesagt da sieht
man mal wie vielfältig er ist letzten
Endes gell wussten sie dass Söder mal
eine Transfrau
war schaut aber wunderschön aus hab
nicht nötig und nochmals na 30 Jahren
dass die Medien das überhaupt nötig
hatten sie hätten es nicht gemacht sie
sind ein direkter junger Mensch aber
nicht h ich das gemacht doch
nein die Süddeutsche hat es gemacht aber
ich hätte es gemacht ich hatte ja nicht
die Infos da hätte ich natürlich h ich
eine riesen Geschichte draus gemacht ja
klar da hätte ich ja eine Beförderung
für gekriegt also da halte ich sie für
seriöse ich bin Null seriös bei Ihnen
vielleicht haben sie eine Jugendsünde da
kann man sich ja inspirieren lassen ja
ich habe mal meinen Lateinlehrer
imitiert aber daran kann ich mich noch
gut erinnern das ist alles das ist alles
das ist ja selbst für bayerische
Verhältnisse tr
würden sie mir gleich 25 Fragen
beantworten gute Freunde kann niemand
trennen ich freue mich sie wieder zu
sehen die Sommerpause die Macht die geht
ja mal dreiviertel Jahr warum eigentlich
für die vielen Gebühren so wenig
arbeiten aber sie schießen aber direkt
scharf hier oder g gelunt Friz neben mir
der ist auch gut gelunt gerade gesagt
friedichz ist euer größter Anhänger
also alles getan Mar zu helfen aber
vermutlich braucht er gar kein Skandal
um die Wahl zu gewinnen und das ist ja
auch schon wieder irgendwie
[Musik]
Skandal hallo Youtube unten könnt ihr
den Kanal abonnieren er deutet nach
unten in die
Infobox neben mir gibt es weitere
interessante Videos Verlinkungen Komma
vielen
[Musik]
Dank